meanwhile let's bring in fox news
contributor retired acting ice director
tom holman
uh tom do you blame trump for the
problems at the border
no i don't and let me address the
statement made by uh
secretary my orchestra there's not a
crisis that that's very disturbing
because when he was a deputy secretary
in 2015 and jay johnson the secretary i
met with them
numerous times a week to talk about the
border crossings how many are crossing
how many be maintained how many being
order removed
and the threshold we sent at the time
brian was a thousand a thousand
crossings a day was a bad day it was a
crisis
and now we're dealing with four thousand
a day four times what he considered a
crisis
back in 2015 he is not being true to the
american people there is certainly a
crisis on the border
that is manufactured and was created by
the bite administration because of their
promises
that they made any tyson say made to the
people 4 000 unaccompanied minors are
now in our country
that's a 19 increase year to year they
have eliminated the war building stop
the remaining mexico policy where 71 000
uh i guess central and south americans
are sitting there waiting i guess
they're going to end up here
uh plus they push their legalizing the
dreamers and
bringing back in deported illegals which
is stunning
along with a hundred day uh pause on
deportations that mexico excuse me
that texas finally went to court to poll
of course there's going to be a crisis
they actually scripted this crisis
and it's not by accident it's by design
you don't have to be a border expert to
realize when you make those type of
promises
and on top of that brian we'll give you
free health care when you make this type
of promises
they're going to come and they knew when
they said these things it was going to
cause a border crisis they have voted to
the progressive left
and it's just incredible he made a
statement yesterday that president trump
gutted the system are you serious he as
a secretary of homeland security he has
more immigration judges he has more
agents
he has more border technology he had
agreements that no other president was
able to get
if anybody's gutted the system is they
gutted this system in the last four
weeks and we see what happened we went
some historic loads
to a crisis unprecedented that is what
they have done
it's not a lack of compassion the
message we send here
forces these triangle countries to send
people in on the hope that they're
getting in
on the promise that they'll get through
instead of going through the system
that allows perhaps more refugees in in
a revamp to immigration reform
but i want to bring it to two more
topics before i have to let you go the
dhs secretary mallorca said yesterday
that loving parents send their kids
alone thousands of miles
through central america through mexico
and we're not going to
be expelling them we're going to we're
not going to apprehend a nine-year-old
who came here alone who travers mexico
whose parents loving parents sent them
here alone
well if we don't send them back tens of
thousands will come
after them we cannot digest in entire
countries
can we no we can't
look it's inhumane to put your children
in the arms of criminal cartels
you and i talked about one of the times
i testify i lost my temper the
congressman and said i didn't care about
dying children
i've held many dying children i was in
back to tractor carrier with
five-year-old little boy suffocated to
death in his father's arms
don't tell me this is compassion putting
your children in the hands of criminal
cartels
is inhumane is dangerous and it's just
bad
so i've seen it and i and i just i can't
believe that statement was even made
it was uh kristen fischer asked this
question yesterday at the white house
briefing
the president of mexico is going to
propose an idea to bring an immigrant
labor
force of 600 to 800 000 immigrants a
year
to work legally in the united states is
that something we should consider the
answer from
uh jen saki i've been i've seen those
reports i believe that's a step that
will require congress
should congress green like this
absolutely
not congress needs to secure our border
and enforce the laws that they wrote
they enacted that was signed by
president and look last year
mexico received 40 billion dollars
in remittances from people here working
the united states illegally
sent money back to mexico 40 billion in
a year of pandemic
so of course the mexican president wants
to send more people here because you
don't have to take care of him
he don't to provide social services he
doesn't have to train them send them to
the united states and send senate's back
even more than 40 billion dollars
this is a win-win for mexico bad for the
united states bad for the american
worker
tom what do they say these are these are
jobs that americans don't want to work
what do you say
that's just untrue that's not true i've
done many investigations
it works like operations where we hit
we've hit uh
work sites where these jobs are
good-paying jobs now some are low-paying
jobs
don't get me wrong but there's a lot of
jobs that middle-class americans would
love to have right now during this time
of unemployment
right plus uh i mean when we're getting
trouble getting off an airplane we had a
report in quarantine
we're letting thousands of people in who
aren't socially distant
who don't travel with rapid tests it's
it's just not logical it's not
there's no compassion involved in this
tom holman thanks so much